this is dangerous and Reckless nuclear
rhetoric it's not new as he has done it
many times before he knows very well
that the nuclear war
should never be fought and cannot be won
and it will have unprecedented
consequences for uh for Russia and
therefore NATO has also increases
military presence especially the Eastern
Port Alliance to remove any room for
miscalculation or misunderstanding in
Moscow
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let us speak plainly
permanent member of the United Nations
security Council invaded its neighbor
attempted to erase a sovereign state
from the map
Russia has shamelessly violated the core
tenets of the United Nations Charter
no more important
than the clear prohibition
against countries taking the territory
of their neighbor by force
again just today
President Putin has made over nuclear
threats against Europe
a reckless disregard
for the responsibilities of the
non-proliferation regime
now
Russia's calling calling up more
soldiers to join the fight
and the Kremlin is organizing a sham
referendum to try to Annex parts of
Ukraine
and extremely significant violation of
the U.N Charter
this world should see these Outrageous
Acts for what they are
Putin claims he had to act because
Russia was threatened
but no one threatened Russia
and no one other than Russia
sought conflict other sanctions should
be imposed on Russia just because we
really need to make sure that the war is
Ended as fast as possible without
sanctions without Unity without help it
will be very hard to do ukrainians are
paying their lives for that so first of
all I think we should be careful about
the exact numbers but of course any
mobilization will add to the number of
troops and forces they have that will
take time and they will require
equipment and what we have seen so far
is that the Russian troops are
ill-equipped they lack proper command
and control and they also have struggled
a lot with Logistics but of course more
troops will escalate the conflict that
will mean more suffering more loss of
lives Ukrainian lives but also Russian
lives President Putin can end this war
by withdrawing his forces by stopping
invading another country this is just
another proof of of Putin that he is not
interested in peace that he's interested
in escalating his war of aggression this
is also yet another sign of his
desperation with how his aggression is
going against Ukraine and as I mentioned
this announcement so this mobilization
partial mobilization together with the
uh with the confirmation of of the
referenda this is clear signal also to
the entire International Community
especially during this crucial week in
the general assembly of the United
Nations in New York this is a clear sign
signal to them that he is only
interested in further advancing and
continuing his destructive War which had
already so many bad consequences
worldwide panic needs
[Music]
is